To calculate Pearson's R in the Google spreadsheet, we write: Equals PEARSON
parentheses, then here we'll have the start cell for variable x, colon, so all
the way to, the end cell for variable x, comma, start cell for variable y, all
the way to the end cell for variable y, close parentheses. About 60 of you took
the poll that I distributed when I announced lesson 12. There were some
interesting results. All the data is below, and there are two pairs of
variables that I want to focus on: Age, and when you arrive at a party, and
Age, and of number of pets. The first thing I want you to do is, visualize the
data. Create a scatter plot for each. Does it look like there's a relationship,
between age and when you arrive at a party? Or between age and number of pets?